i mean even before i started playing the
pro
i made a video game with rockstar games
so the name of the game is called
rockstar presents table tennis
it's the only look at his face it's it's
the only
non-violent game that rockstar has ever
made
what yeah when did it come out 2006 2006
0007
it's the only game that rockstar made
that's non-violent it's called rockstar
presents table tennis
and um the way i gotta pull that [ __ ] up
aiden
that's your cue man the way i got to
make this game
was that um i was at a tournament local
tournament in chinatown
and uh i was playing kid from china who
just came from china and
and we were fighting out and the kid was
like and i was like that's it baby come
on
come on he's going down he's going i was
talking mad trash and they were scouting
actually they were rock star games with
scouting and i know rockstar game
because i'm a big fan of grand theft
auto
right so they were scouting and then
they came up to me
and they said hey we we love your energy
we love the character character you put
out they were like uh do you know
rockstar games like hell yeah i know
russell games crazy grand theft auto
yeah i play every one
and then we're like well we want to make
we're interested in making a tableton's
game i was like what he's like
are you will you be interested hell yeah
i wasn't even thinking about money i was
like thinking i was like yeah for sure
definitely definitely definitely so hell
yeah i made this game with them
um the game won best sports game of the
year it beat
madden he beat nba live every game
it destroyed every game because it was
it was just a fun game that you could
it was easy to play but hard to master
but it was an easy game when you can get
up and play it
and so and we marketed this game like
all over the place like i was in japan
like
in this crazy apartment having parties
with different
like it'd be one that would be hip-hop
night or tech night and they would come
to play the game and i would talk with
them and sign autographs no way
and that's how i started playing pro
tour so we skipped a lot of it but
that's how i started playing pro tour
because
after i told rox i said hey listen i
want to play pro
so can you guys sponsor me and they were
like yeah and i was like all right so i
came up with a
plan of how much money i needed boom
gave it to them and they agreed cut a
check yup and that's how i played and
that's how i played pro
although because you got to pay money to
play all over the world i went to every
major
country in the world to play on rockstar
money wow that's [ __ ]
dope dude yeah yeah yeah it's cool what
is this there's screenshots from it
you can't find no video video look at
that
that's so cool here we go i got the game
in my house still fine wally you got
did they make you your own character no
what and you know what and it's actually
my fault
i should have pushed for it the reason
why i didn't make the my character
is because they thought that i would
charge
to have me but i wouldn't i would i
would let him do it for free because
there's a black dude there
yeah it could have been me they probably
based him off of you maybe well actually
every character is based off my emotion
oh really every every character did they
dress you up in one of those suits yeah
yeah
no way yeah the motion capture the
motion capture suit yeah yeah i wore
that
and listen it's one of the hardest
things motion capture
is insanely difficult it is crazy
it is it is just nuts because you have
to do
every possible motion that's possible in
a game that may not be possible in real
life
so for example if if i make a stroke
this works this works this
is not something we do but you have to
do it anyway because you have to cover
every possible spectrum because even if
it works or doesn't work yes because of
the video game
and then oh [ __ ] here's the video yeah
there you go oh look at this is
nuts yeah this game looks pretty sick
yeah it is for me it's the most closest
until today there's there's you can tell
it's rockstar too just the way the art
the art looks
it looks like that grand theft auto
really really nuts
damn that's [ __ ] cool yeah so
i mean it was it was a really good time
and
and because of them i was able to play
all over the world
that's so [ __ ] cool man so the motion
how long did it take for you to do all
that motion capture [ __ ] that was a
while
uh that was a while it was really
difficult
because like i said you have to cover
every every
every possible movement has to be
covered for the video game
so so with somebody there like directing
yeah yeah they direct you it's really
hard because
so so for example let's say the movement
the feet movement if you start like this
you have to end like this or you gotta
do it over so
if i start with this foot in front and
this foot back so let's say i need to go
there i go one two
boom i gotta come back gotta make sure i
end like this
if i end like this we gotta do it over
so i have to go
this way boom this way this way boom
this way
and then lunges like making like your
lunges
yeah you know every possible thing you
have to do it
so they can record it yeah so it was it
was definitely not easy
how long did it take i i don't i don't
remember i it was i think maybe
i don't remember may was a week i don't
remember but it was multiple shoots
yeah it was really hard it was it was
like physically
hard wow you know because because you
have to like
like i said you you have to cover every
possible motion
yeah so it was fun and because of them
you know i've got to play
you know pro tour all over the world man
i was watching the uh like a behind the
scenes clip
behind the scenes clip from the uh
forrest gump movie when they were
showing how tom hanks would play the do
the ping-pong scenes
and he actually just had to like fake
the movement the movie yeah and they
they like the cgi they cgi the ball it's
almost like the same thing with uh the
bruce lee thing you ever seen the bruce
lee thing
no you've never seen the bruce lee thing
what what thing oh my
god you ever seen the bruce lee thing
what do you what thing are you talking
about
tell him to pull it up pull up put bruce
lee ping-pong
you've never seen this i don't think so
okay i'm not gonna say anything oh
[ __ ] watch this i'm not gonna say
anything
i get now when i get questions
i get thousands and thousands and
thousands on questions
on this video really every time watch
when you see it
yeah yeah this this watch this watch
this full screen it give me
give us audio thousands of questions on
this
every time this is the most question i
get
about this video
what the [ __ ] you watch has got to be
fake it is
but it's a really that is pretty [ __ ]
exciting he's using numbers
it's a really good cgi
oh my god with a shaky camera
holy [ __ ]
oh my god that's [ __ ] amazing yo it's
nuts
so what is this for i don't know i i
i've seen this video i get i get mail on
this all the time like people always ask
me they're asking if it's real is it
real yeah
that's some really good [ __ ] cgi work
very good especially with the shaky
camera
look at that i mean that shaky camera
makes it look so legit
could you imagine dude it's crazy
now now now here's the thing a lot of
people think it's real
it's a commercial for a phone oh there
you go a lot of people think it's real
but because i play i know it's not real
right because a nunchuck is
is is a circular circular and there's no
way
he'd be able to hit that ball so precise
if it was flat maybe it's possible but
it's totally impossible and
then if you look at the trajectory of
how he hits that ball would not go
straight it would actually go
up so i know this but a lot of people
don't like people have argued with me
before and i'm like they think it's real
yeah they think it's real
it's not real that's a pretty [ __ ]
sick video it's a good cg
that is a really good cgi very very good
one very good holy crap bro
so [ __ ] rockstar sponsored you to go
all over the world now you're now you're
pro
yeah you're rockstar pro they're paying
you i had had rockstar gear
i i think i may still have one shirt
left in the house i gave a lot of it
away
like as i was traveling through the
world and and uh
and going to these different countries
you know
one thing that you can give to fans is
your shirt
like giving a shirt with your name on it
like fans
fans want this stuff yeah so so i like i
would give away my rockstar shirts and
give the
hell yeah give stuff away to fans and
stuff like that
i